what about operation northwoods
it was a proposed 1962 false flag
operation by the dod
and
the cia to be carried out by the cia to
commit acts of terrorism on americans
and blame them on cuba
so jfk the president rejected the
proposal
what do you make that this was on the
table operation northwoods so it's
interesting
first i'm glad that jfk rejected it
that's uh
that's a good sign
so
we have to understand that good ideas
are oftentimes born from bad ideas
i had a really good friend of mine who
actually went on to become a pastor
and he used to say all the time that he
wanted all the bad ideas on the table
like give me all your bad ideas every
time we had any kind of conversation and
i i was always one of those people who's
like isn't a bad idea just a waste of
time
and he was like no because the best
ideas oftentimes come from bad ideas so
again cuban missile crisis
uh
mass hysteria in the united states about
nuclear war from cuba missiles blowing
up american cities faster than we could
even see them coming it makes sense to
me that a president would go to
especially the part of cia which is the
special activities division it makes
perfect sense to me that the president
would go to a division called special
activities whose job it is to create
you know
crazy ideas that have presidential uh
approval but nobody knows they exist
so it makes sense that he would
challenge a group like that to come up
with any wacky idea right come up with
anything just let's start with something
because we can't have we can't bring
nothing to the table we have to do
something about this cuban issue and
then that's how an operation like that
could reasonably be born not because
anybody wants to do it but because they
were tasked by the president to come up
with five ideas
and it was one of the ideas
that still happens to this day
the president will still come in but
will basically send out a notice to his
covert action arm and he will say
i need this
and i need it on wednesday and people
have to come back with options for the
thing he asked for
a finding he will issue a presidential
finding and then his covert action arms
have to come back and say here's how we
would do this and hide the hands of the
americans
how gangster was it of jfk to reject it
though this baller right
that's like that is the that is a mic
drop right there nope not doing that so
yep doing that
you know a thing
that crosses an ethical line even in it
in a time where the human
the entirety of human civilization hangs
in a balance still forfeit that power
that's um
that's a beautiful thing about the
american experiment that's a few times
throughout the history that has happened
including with our first president
george washington
you